bonjour à tous et à toutes ces infos
départ alors bonjour à tous et à toutes
voilà on est en direct
l'académie a été très sensible à votre
présentation des césars et a décidé de
vous offrir cette oscar où l'aï
représentation de l'onmt a pas fait le
voyage pour rien bah c'est gentil la
france il a totalement fondu
jérôme commandeur les femmes c'est une
star risque est que dieu à l'homme de
karaté tous touchants mais c'est
possible
tout le team compte fait je vais pas
trop vous demander monsieur je voudrais
pas trop en dire mais crise que ça va
être plein de runner qu'est ce que vous
pouvez nous dire déjà prôné mort
d'impatience vous savez ça c'est entre
nous on le dit à personne et ce sac à
main bonjour bonjour mes pensées et
voilà vous venez d'assister en direct à
un piratage d'interview oui vive le
france oui
comment ça va enfin nous avons regardé
isabelle voilà c'est comme ça de quoi là
ben vous les voulez vous les jours
passent au mien non ça va être joli
week-end magnifique
comment vous vivez tout ça vous avez le
temps de comme on dit qui fait tout ça
nous ça va tellement vite que
franchement là j'ai le temps parce que
vous avez vu la taille du red carpet
alors là j'ai tout le temps dans 54 m
voilà franchement c'est très très long
donc on attend vraiment d'apprécier de
goûter chaque moment bien sûr et puis ya
beaucoup d'heures de joie et de plaisir
à être ici
oui j'ai la chance de faire quelque
chose que j'aime énormément
j'aime aussi ne rien faire vous avez des
périodes de wasit fêter ça vous arrive
d'accord c'est vraiment comment vous
faites compétents dernier non mais je
veux dire c'est quoi et du scrabble non
je me promène voilà oui je regarde
l'année je flâne oui oui c'est très
curieuse je regarde les gens quant à
elle elle dit j'aime ne rien faire c'est
d'une classe absolue
et quand c'est moi qu'ils disent les
feignants doit percer mais la différence
regarder en direct sur canal+
pardon mais j'ai je suis aussi sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est bon parce que j'ai
40 ans que je à moi aussi je suis dans
les média trust
vas-y vas-y jérôme ouais c'est pas mal
ça c'est bien
voilà regardez là voilà voilà et jérôme
commandeur c'est un bel père bravo
pardon d'avoir coupé yéménite on ne
regarde écrite avec nous sting bonsoir
comment ça va
twitter qu'est ce que vous faites
je me suis réveillée comme ça gemalto ce
matin j'ai passé quinze jours à peu près
puis j'ai mis ces données costume les
gardes et en fait je l'avais déjà
semaine dernière je n'ai pas quitté
voilà moi je suis mort de rire parce que
c'est vrai que il a réussi à creuser
quand même sa question en aussi bravo
georges et il avait très beaux cheveux
et ça méritait de nom c'est vrai c'est
vrai ce sera repris sur les réseaux on
sait pas mais il a dit que c'est pas
pris de douche c'est comme ça que je
comprends pas l'anglais mais on refaire
oui absolument
oui relais avec madame honneur l
histoire dont didier didier tendance est
à oui c'est ça didier voilà renseigne la
jeune femme
commandeur bonjour bonsoir bonsoir
hockey à come to see you tube office
or hier mon père est très joli col châle
10 de col châle alors agir oui moi
j'adore d'arcachon gp du surf là bas si
les gens qui me regardent d'arcachon
j'espère revenir bientôt
et quand on se rassemble on prendra une
pizza moi j'adore la france
jérôme bien d'arcachon adore vraiment et
voilà c'est toute vérité c'est toujours
fascinant c'est une ya vingt ans que
j'ai participé pour la terre fois aux
oscars c'est comme un festival de
gonfler cette fois combien si c'était
pour très exaltant d'être là pour ce
week-end merci salma vous passer de
trois ans consécutifs à salma hayek qui
vous dit d'un regard si seulement on
adore ici elle se voit qu'une actrice
par french et les ballons l'invs en
général quand jérôme didier lange
charlize theron la ba oui mon âge on a
mouillé le maillot
on est allé on ya cru un vrai jeu de
mots bonjour comme battle est très bien
quoi vous sentez vous nicole kidman qui
est nommé pour le meilleur second rôle
féminin dans la yom là ils ont mis
exactement en français c'est fou parce
que si je lui avais chaud et son petit
groupe de riches pouvaient masquer une
villa dans le lubéron toi comme j'en
avais déjà trop tardé à tollec clac
octobre il amélie par isabelle huppert
une hauteur end prochain voilà justin
timberlake je te le faire passer aux
oubliettes dans les douves tout ce qu'on
pas voulu répondre
scarlett johansson je peux te dire un
peu aller chercher un boulot parce que
alors saga legends qu'on va avoir
bientôt bynum a primé dans un film qui
me ding pas le maximum de la sympathie
un peu quand même je suis sting quoi le
français tu vas au trouve un peu dur
gérard j'ai trouvé un peu faim tapis
c'est un peu un peu plus non mais on
allait donc c'est là on est à la fin du
tapis d'ailleurs monique frizot aussi
qui est nommé au meilleur sens
pour son fils jérôme et très en forme il
est en train ça y est le jet lag en
avoir raison d'eux jérôme commandeur et
en attendait l'histoire c'est que on la
sortie française pour les dédier le
réalisateur a pu recaser montrer comment
ce cher il a dit à monsieur oui à la
plus grande dit rien ça ferait bien
plaisir et il le rappeler n'a rien à
[ __ ] moi cette anecdote elle est
complètement con votre éditeur parisien
j'ai réalisé un film son premier module
wii à jeremy renner combien de temps
passé en b2c ont été présentés le ns je
ne veux pas que vous me parliez regarder
devrait aller on va se ressaisir chef de
jazz qui devrait gagner l'oscar en effet
monsieur harvey weinstein avait beaucoup
ému lola et les deux émetteurs là les
stagiaires de l'école de journalisme de
de cambrai et là tout le monde est de
doubler par là on regarde pardon j'ai
dit j'ai un jeu lille je tiens un peu
l'antenne parce que c'est un peu
désordonné
me regarder impressionné mais oui mais
je suis très heureux de commenter cette
cérémonie est bien et j'ai pas mal de
choses à dire sur le cinéma mondial là
ça va eh bien écoutez je vous laisse
aller j'ai eu des idées préconçues là